um what is degree.com who are your
customers how do you make money how do
you charge for the product
what's the outcome you're selling with
this software platform
yeah the the genesis and the vision was
tell me about your education
and when when people go skip
10 15 20 years of their lives to answer
with university
it's a reflection of this need and
opportunity in the market
and our vision was to create a model of
lifelong learning where people could
answer for
all of their real-time education and
skills
all of their academics all of their
personal informal learning all of their
professional training
and that's what we built we started in
circa 2012 sort of you know fitbit and
quantified self was
was a big theme so that that sort of
theme of tracking
and reflecting was a big one um you know
uh and you know where it's taken us
is this currency as we look in the
the the rear view mirror the currency
that we transacted on was the college
degree
but as we look forward the the needs of
the workplace
the demand force half-life of skills is
coming down that means we have to learn
more and more
the the skills gap is growing the
war for skilled talent remains even
amongst
covid unemployment we're in an
environment where
there's a high level of need for
particular skills and that's created a
pressure and an opportunity and the
future of work the currency will be
skills
um it increasingly is we've seen it with
google we've seen it
um from google just made an announcement
right they just made this announcement
google announces a hundred thousand
scholarships for online certificates in
data analytics project management and ux
google basically is saying hey you know
what colleges are offering
we're just going to do ourselves correct
they're they're looking
to just find talented people and teach
them what they need in
you know college degree credential be be
damned
we're now the credentialer if you pass
one of those certificates
they waive um sort of any degree
requirement